where'd you grow up can i have philly
philly north do you think that
f n o r f i grew up in chicago yeah and
my experience with cops in chicago
very bad my experience with cops in
smaller towns and suburbs great
phenomenal
amazing amazing amazing especially
sheriffs yeah and i think you made that
point
you elect sheriffs yep so they're
accountable they got to get those votes
they got to be careful right
in chicago i felt like you're faceless
they don't know you they don't care and
so i think one of the one of the issues
is that once again even when it comes to
the gun debate yeah urban versus rural
yeah people who live in the middle of
nowhere are like don't take my guns i
need it what am i gonna do i can't call
the cops
people live in cities like cops are
right there i can call them if i need to
you know what i mean yeah
so people who live out in rural areas
even in suburban areas
where you've got smaller departments
you've got and even some of these
smaller suburban departments are
militarized it's crazy they got m wraps
armored vehicles and all that stuff
even uh so so you have a lot of these
people who have a more positive
experience
they're not going to understand what's
going on in cities right and why people
in cities are upset
but the same is true in the other
direction right so when these people are
like we're going to abolish the police
yeah that's like i get it man but you're
you're you're going from zero to 100 in
two seconds
you you abolishing the police and still
making everything
lawful it's very simple there should be
police
this part is my opinion there should be
police for
crimes with actual victims agreed
so like i think trump should pardon
we've talked about this like
non-violent drug offenders get out of
here review them to make sure they
weren't
plea pleading down right you might have
a guy who like beat the crap out of
somebody but then took a plea
this is where i disagree i believe
that you go to jail for the thing that
you want you are
sentenced for you have a trial by jury
of your peers
and they go you know what tim that time
you robbed maj we gotta
we gotta give you two years and tim's
behind bars for two years
tim eats works out tim comes out super
duper swole
tim should be able to get back to his
life i agree
i now regret now to me this is where
again objectivity and people get upset
i don't care what your crime is i don't
care
if he's outside he's not a danger to
society
if he is a danger to society he's not
outside i don't know man what if he's a
pedo
this is where it gets hairy right
because these people will re-offend
and if they do they go back to jail now
this is
so so but i can't it's like thomas paine
said i can't
let's be clear i think pedophiles
are weirdos that
i want to say this without incriminating
myself
if you're a pedophile and
i catch you
it's gonna be a bad day for you yeah or
a last day for you or
last day for you potentially you never
know it's the roll of the dice
with that being the case because i don't
want to say it it's like premeditated
this is
all i have right right right in defense
of someone else in defense of another
life
right i believe that that pedophile that
i think is the scum of the earth
should go to jail should come outside
and he's paid his debt to society do you
believe in the death
do you support the death penalty yes
what would you give the death penalty
for
um for death you kill somebody at death
penalty
yep if it's unjustified like like like
like the weirdo what's the what's the
kid
uh that they took the burger king uh
dylan roof
yeah right we're not wasting a bunch of
time here
let's give him a j let's give him a
trial by jury i'm i'm extremely
hard on people that take life
i'm extremely hard on people that rape
and for rape i would have a different
set of things but
death for me would be people that kill
people you know rape's an interesting
one because there's two kinds of there's
statutory rape and then there's
forced intercourse and they're
completely different experiences as
someone that was falsely accused of
statutory rape
that's an area with rape in general but
more specifically both of those
i'm like yo we got a fine-tooth calmness
because i know a dude that just came
home
for like 40 years for rape
statutory rape regular see this i think
we should change what that's called
statutory rape and do another
word i think that rape is and my my home
girls are always upset me
upset when i say this i think rape is
forcible you know remember when aziz
ansari the comedian
um like bad date yeah the girl said like
he didn't threaten me he didn't make me
feel uncomfortable
but like she wound up you know giving
him fellatio twice that night
and then she told her homegirl was like
yo i think
like i didn't like it and she's like oh
girl you were raped
and the homegirl that she was talking to
like wrote a piece on it yup
mind you he didn't she by her own
admission is like he didn't force me
he didn't threaten me he didn't make me
feel uncomfortable after the fact
now he's gonna that's not rape well she
did say she felt uncomfortable
you felt uncomfortable but you give him
a bj twice
because because he did this like hey
so so i'll tell you right now like it's
really interesting
you consider yourself a libertarian
absolutely and i would like i'm a
libertarian that has strong
conservative values right i think that's
what i thought was interesting you
mentioned you were for the death penalty
because yeah like
aren't libertarians mostly against that
yeah they are mostly
a lot of libertarians are um against
border
security not right exactly i'm four
borders
i'm with borders with nations that if
okay so like there's really really
beautiful women in india
in japan right i can't like japan's not
gonna let me go over there and just hang
out forever
after that visa is up japan's gonna be
like
okay bro time to get out of here
if your nation doesn't let me hang out
forever in your town then our nation
shouldn't let you
hang out in our in our town so
and you can't have bor no open borders
in like a welfare state everybody you
won't have a nation after that exactly
that's like sweden
you're right you know because if
everybody's getting if
everyone's getting access to a social
program and you're not from the town
and they're not refilling that it would
be like if you had a
if you had a big pizza and you said
anybody can come in and take the pizza
but only you got to pay for it it's like
well i'm going to stop paying for it
right no you can't well eventually
there's no pizza left for anybody
so that so that libertarian and strong
concern and a lot of conservatives call
themselves conservatives but they're
really statists
right they're just trump supporters that
are riding the wave
of president trump right or their status
they're not
defined status like what do you mean
it's like a bootlicker
a person that you know is well the
government
let me tell you i'm sorry man yeah the
people when those cops came and took the
guns from the mccloskeys
yeah i was out i was furious right they
didn't they didn't do anything wrong
according to the law according to the ag
right they were defending their property
people broke out of their property and
the cops came
and the mccloskeys were like turn around
so no one sees you i'm like no these
guys came and stole your guns dude
now here's the funny thing i agree with
you
i think they were unsafe when i see the
the oh yeah dude for sure three knuckles
deep
oh like waving the gun that's what
that's where they lose me if they would
have been at the low right first of all
you got a scarface house with like a
balcony
like you can like be out the balcony and
like you got the high grade listen
listen man
i disagree you know why i think i i get
what you're saying about her you know
walk in and pointing yeah but if you if
you if you live on your house you have a
right to bear arms
you do we can't we can't we can't be
like you have to have a certain skill
level no no no no i'm not saying i'm not
saying
i absolutely don't think that they their
firearms should have been taken
right right right absolutely i'm not
trying to implement i'm saying as
a as a as a person that deals with
conflict resolution
so you gotta you know how to be like
well we gotta look at the full story
right
the full story they didn't break that
gate down now did they trespass
because they walked through where a sign
was supposed to yes they did
the back for the back story is they
weren't going to the mccluskey's house
they were still on like a public street
in a private neighborhood
it was a private street it was a private
street in a it's a private street but
not like
on the mccluskey's like porch right
right they were going past the
mccluskey's house
because a few days before that the mayor
of that town lived in that town the
mayor doxed
like protesters on the internet
literally read their addresses literally
so okay you're reading our addresses out
so we're gonna come to your address now
they did trespass because it was a
private community
they did not like television was like oh
they just shook the door and broke the
gate down
i have the video of them like some dude
like with like a he looked like he was
from the purge like a black suit on
like opening the door and he was holding
it open for him yeah now you still
did trespass because you crossed past
that threshold somebody
somebody did break the gate though yes
because there's footage
not the people that initially walked in
so they were walking past the
mccluskey's house
the mccluskies to their uh uh to their
uh perspective saw all of these people
and they're like what the hell is going
on
so they go out on their on their land
now i disagree with them
from a safety and conflict resolution
standpoint
me even if i completely disagreed with
all those people walking past
i'm gonna de-escalate even if i would
have came out and went
you don't know what i think in my head
they would have kept walking past the
house now do the mccluskies have to do
that no
they don't where they lost me was when
they started waving
firearms at americans and their lives
were not in imminent danger
that whole that they so hold on i fear
for my life thing
if if you and i as lawful and safe gun
owners
we don't get to use you can in some
states
i because i can and should i are two
different things could and should
i'm not pulling my firearm out until
it's time to shoot
jason voorhees so you're not supposed to
point at something unless you're ready
to destroy it yep
so in that yeah like i think the
mccloskeys were violating
you know a few of the cardinal rules
right but they said
these people were threatening them
saying we're going to take your house
we're going to burn that's going to be
my room things like that
and let me ask you another question if
if you were in your house
and then you saw a large angry group you
know come on come on to private property
and are they walking past you don't know
it's just a large group and they're had
to have your direction i gotta watch
and you see a dude pull out something
that looks like a long black barrel and
start pointing at your house what do you
do
me yeah i watch and i get covered if
they if they if they point that at you
you're not gonna get low ready you're
not gonna pull out your gun you're not
gonna say hey yo what are you doing no
if i'm first of all in that scenario
i'm not coming outside tactically it's
dumb to do that that's like if somebody
breaks into my house i have a plan
if someone breaks into my house
depending on what floor they're on and
if it's late at night
i'm i m my family already has the plan
of what we're going to do everybody's
going to
locate in this room i got the ar ready
i'm going to yell out
we're armed the police have been called
please leave once they get past a
certain point
i am going to swish cheese them now
for me in that scenario that you give
some guys outside i don't know if it's a
fire armor not it looks like 300 people
300 people and they walking past
until you don't know they're walking
past i don't know that yeah i have to
watch
some people are yelling we're going to
burn your house down cool yell all day
and then some dude takes his long black
thing he points it right at it right
cool do it i can find concealment and
cover in my house
from a tactical and strategic standpoint
that's what i do would
would you fault someone for assuming
that if someone you know is in this mob
and someone has something that looks
like a long black barrel
would you would you fault someone for
thinking i got to defend myself yeah but
you don't defend yourself by going
towards the gun
that's stupid so it just tells me that
that person doesn't have training
and and i think that's obvious yeah like
it's just doing this the reason i ask is
because there's a photo
and a lot of people get this wrong yeah
i've seen this before go around a guy's
holding a
what looks like a shotgun mic a long
shotgun
and if you don't know anything about
cameras yeah people are looking at this
and there's a guy literally holding a
long black barrel and pointing it at him
and i see that i'm like he's got a
shotgun mic on a dslr right it's a
camera
the mccloskeys might have saw that and
we're like they're screaming at us
they're saying we're going to burn your
house down
they didn't say that until after they
came outside though
see see that escalated that
and i'm not saying they're they're on be
clear
they're on their property i don't think
that their gun should have been
confiscated
but they are not um safe and responsible
gun owners but
from a tactical perspective you have the
high ground you have a stone house you
have concealment and cover
you have rifles you have the element of
surprise you didn't take a second to
wait and watch now if if
if it's they come through the gate they
shoot and absolutely get busy from
from absolutely but that's not what
happened i just i feel like the
challenge is
i definitely what you're saying i feel
the challenges
what if somebody's a gun owner and
they're just really dumb
but they're on their property there's a
crowd there like
i you know the challenge is if you go to
somebody else's house
yeah and they're scared yeah even if
they're they have no idea how to use a
gun
yeah holding it backwards and pointing
at themselves or whatever it's like
no i don't fault them at all yeah the
where the but
i think your points are fair like they
come out they've got the rifle and she's
pointing at waving it this
teachable moment is i want the
mccluskies to get training
for sure and i don't i don't want i
don't want
i'm glad that no one was harmed i'm glad
that
um it it spoke to a bigger picture
do i think that the state should have
showed up to take their guns absolutely
not i think that was like
political theater i don't think they're
going to like
face charges and no i i see two
bootlickers
two different kinds of bull lickers
right now you've got people cheering on
as the cop
sees the weapon from leak from gun
owners who for for all their faults had
a legal right to defend their property
yeah but then you got the the other side
you've got these businesses
and this one this one i'm actually i
empathize and i feel bad
you've got businesses that literally get
ransacked by
you know antifa far leftist riders and
then come out and say but we support
them
that's bootlicking too i get it i get
why
so bootlicking has to be so deter yes
i agree somewhat but the terminology and
how the term boot licking is used
is tied to the state i get it for sure
but yes
but i also understand there's guys that
my my business has insurance
they're going to cake up that's not so
in minneapolis that's maybe not
right so all of these businesses be
because of uh
a handful of them there's a big story
about this the the rubble removal
yeah exceeded the cost that insurance
covered because most people didn't think
they were going to have to deal with a
pilot
smoldering rubble right right so it's
like they're done they're gone forever
now it's like their lives are destroyed
right and those are the areas where
that black lives matter movement um
it started from ferguson well started
black lives matter was trayvon martin
even before trey trayvon in fergus
trayvon
and mike brown in ferguson darren seals
there was a group of people i went to
ferguson talked to darren's uh mike
brown's dad
talked to uh darren seals who was a very
powerful
figure he literally there's video of him
saying because it turned from the
ferguson movement
to black lives matter it got co-opted
years ago before he was murdered shot in
the head shot in a vehicle i went to
where his dad was
no not my ground oh oh darren seals oh
wow
three of the five men that started that
ferguson movement
three of them have been murdered two of
them shot
in their car darren seals his car set on
fire
the ferguson police department is
calling it a suicide
not even investigating it went to i went
to that ferguson market
they're still law enforcement posted up
at the ferguson market
i asked those law enforcement they're
like yeah they knew
they knew that there were two sets of
videos they sent one to the department
of justice
all these different things my point in
saying that is even darren seal said
years ago five six years ago
black lives matter as the organization
just got five hundred thousand dollars
from google
it is not what we it's been co-opted
five six years ago
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you